AN OVERWHELMINGLY NO VOTE
TONIGHT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WAS EXPRESSED TONIGHT.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON WHAT WE SAID
YES TO AS A STATE.
WE SAID YES TO SCIENCE.
WE SAID YES TO VACCINES.
WE SAID YES TO ENDING THIS
PANDEMIC.
WE SAID YES TO PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO
VOTE WITHOUT FEAR OF FAKE FRAUD
OR VOTER SUPPRESSION.
WE SAID YES TO WOMEN'S
FUNDAMENTAL CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO DECIDE FOR HERSELF WHAT SHE
DOES WITH HER BODY AND HER FATE
AND FUTURE.
WE SAID YES TO DIVERSITY.
WE SAID YES TO INCLUSION.
WE SAID YES TO PLURALISM.
WE SAID YES TO ALL THOSE THINGS
THAT HE WE HOLD DEAR AS
CALIFORNIANS AND I WOULD ARGUE
AS AMERICANS.
ECONOMIC JUSTICE, SOCIAL
JUSTICE, RACIAL JUSTICE,
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
OUR VALUES, WHERE CALIFORNIA'S
MADE SO MUCH PROGRESS.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS WERE ON THE
BALLOT THIS EVENING.
AND SO I'M HUMBLED AND GRATEFUL
TO THE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT EXERCISED
THEIR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO VOTE
AND EXPRESS THEMSELVES SO
OVERWHELMINGLY BY REJECTING THE
DIVISION, BY REJECTING THE
CYNICISM, BY REJECTING SO MUCH
OF THE NEGATIVITY THAT'S DEFINED
OUR POLITICS IN THIS COUNTRY
OVER THE COURSE OF OF SO MANY
YEARS.
I JUST THINK OF OUR KIDS
WATCHING ALL THIS.
NIGHTLY NEWS DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
AND I JUST WONDER, I'VE GOT FOUR
YOUNG KIDS.
OLDEST ABOUT TO TURN 12 THIS
WEEKEND.
AND WHAT THEY'RE GROWING UP TO
IN A WORLD WE'RE SO DIVIDED,
THESE KIDS INCREASINGLY FEARFUL,
ISOLATED, DISCONNECTED.
AND WE'RE TEACHING THEM THAT.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT WAY.
I THINK WE OWE OUR KIDS A DEEPER
SENSE OF RESPECT AND ALL OF US
AS ADULTS RESPONSIBILITY TO
DISREGARD THIS FALSE
SEPARATENESS.
WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE IN COMMON
AS A STATE AND A NATION THAN WE
GIVE OURSELVES CREDIT FOR.
I'VE BEEN ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS BUT NOTABLY IN THE LAST
NINE MONTHS.
CONSERVATIVE PARTS OF THE STATE,
PROGRESSIVE PARTS OF THE STATE,
FOLKS THAT I KNOW WERE GOING TO
VOTE NO AND FOLKS THAT I KNEW
WERE GOING TO VOTE YES ON THIS
RECALL AND TURNED OUT TO DO JUST
THAT.
BUT ONE THING THAT'S UNIVERSAL,
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE RESPECTED.
EVERYONE WANTS TO FEEL SOME
CONNECTION TO ONE ANOTHER.
WE ALL CERTAINLY IN THIS
PANDEMIC WANT TO FEEL SAFE,
PROTECTED.
THOSE ARE UNIVERSAL VALUES.
AND I THINK ABOUT JUST IN THE
LAST FEW DAYS, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT PUT OUT SAYING THIS
ELECTION WAS RIGGED.
DEMOCRACY IS NOT A FOOTBALL.
YOU DON'T THROW IT AROUND.
IT'S MORE LIKE A -- I DON'T
KNOW, AN ANTIQUE VASE.
YOU CAN DROP IT AND SMASH IT IN
A MILLION DIFFERENT PIECES.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE CAPABLE OF
DOING IF WE DON'T STAND UP TO
MEET THE MOMENT AND PUSH BACK.
I SAID THIS MANY, MANY TIMES ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
YOU KNOW, WE MAY HAVE DEFEATED
TRUMP, BUT TRUMPISM IS NOT DEAD
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE BIG LIE.
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
ALL THE VOTING SUPPRESSION
EFFORTS THAT ARE HAPPENING ALL
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
ASSAULT ON FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS,
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHTS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
IT'S A REMARKABLE MOMENT IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY.
BUT I'M REMINDED OF SOMETHING, I
DON'T KNOW, A FEW DECADES AGO
SOMEONE TOLD ME WHEN DESCRIBING
A DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING
MOMENT.
SAID THE WORLD IS TOO SMALL, OUR
TIME IS TOO SHORT, AND OUR
WISDOM IS TOO LIMITED TO WIN
FLEETING VICTORIES AT OTHER
PEOPLE'S EXPENSES.
AND HE WENT ON TO SAY WE MUST
ALL TRIUMPH TOGETHER.
SO IN THAT SPIRIT OF RECOGNIZING
AND RECONCILING THIS MOMENT AND
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON NOT JUST HERE IN THE
STATE BUT ALL ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA, I JUST WANT
TO SAY THIS.
TONIGHT I'M HUMBLED, GRATEFUL,
BUT RESOLVED IN THE SPIRIT OF MY
POLITICAL HERO, ROBERT KENNEDY,
TO MAKE MORE GENTLE THE LIFE OF
THIS WORLD.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH, AND
THANK YOU TO 40 MILLION
AMERICANS, 40 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS, AND THANK YOU FOR
REJECTING THIS RECALL.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
>> DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM SPEAKING THERE IN
SACRAMENTO AFTER AN OVERWHELMING
LANDSLIDE OF A VICTORY.
THE NO TO THE RECALL MOVEMENT
WINNING OVERWHELMINGLY.
AND DANA BASH, FIRST OF ALL, WE
SHOULD NOTE, HE'S STILL IN HIS
FIRST TERM.
IN ABOUT SIX MONTHS, IN MARCH,
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO START
DOING THIS ALL OVER AGAIN TO WIN
A SECOND TERM.
BUT BEYOND THAT THIS WAS A --
THE SPEECH HE JUST GAVE SEEMED A
NATIONAL SPEECH.
IT WAS NOT JUST ABOUT
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS NOT JUST ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
IT WAS ABOUT -- TO BE COMPLETELY
CANDID, IT SOUNDED ALMOST LIKE A
2024, 2028 PRESIDENTIAL SPEECH.
>> WHICH IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE.
>> CAMPAIGN SPEECH.
>> IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE.
AND THE RESOUNDING NO VOTE THAT
YOU SAW THERE CERTAINLY HOPES
THAT CASE IF HE DECIDES TO GO
THAT ROUTE.
BUT YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT IS A NATIONAL MESSAGE.
THERE IS A ROAD MAP TH